It's time to thread up the machine
and get knitting. Before we get started.
Be sure you're using a yarn that's
the appropriate weight for your machine.
Do you need yarn on cones
for machine knitting?
No.
All you need is to have the yarn
wound in a way that it will
easily feed into the machine.
Often you can use a center pull
ball from a yarn manufacturer.
Some knitters will use a ball winder
and rewind everything.
Skins, Hanks, balls, everything.
If your ball Winder creates a flat bottom
ball, you can also use the yarn
from the outside of the ball.
Do whatever works for you.
You don't want to spend a whole
lot of time dealing with knots
as you're knitting.
Let's thread up the machine.
Working on the right side of the mast,
take the end of the working yarn
and thread it through the loop
in the triangular yarn guide.
You'll then pass it through
the mast tension dial.
Be sure to place the yarn
between the discs.
Notice that there's a post inside.
Be sure that the yarn
passes under that post.
Adjust the tension dial
to the middle setting.
Aligning the two triangles
for now. As you work with different yarns,
you can adjust the flow of the yarn here
based on the thickness of the yarn.
This tension dial, along with the carriage
tension dial, impacts
the gauge of your knitting.
Place the yarn in the front
loop of the front arm feeder.
Reach up and grab the right
take-up spring and pass
the yarn through the loop.
Secure the yarn in the clip.
I'm a mask to temporarily hold it.
This is how your mast should look.
We'll start with some plain knitting
first, we'll need to get the yarn
on the needles and form some stitches.
The Caston we'll be using is a little
different from the manual,
and you'll see why
in a minute.
Be sure your carriage is
set for plain knitting.
Now this is a term you're
going to become familiar with.
So take a mental picture.
Tension dial 6-8,
depending on your yarn.
Holding Cam lever to N.
No Cam buttons engaged.
Use the release lever.
Make sure they're all out.
Set the change knob to N.
The carriage is on the right.
Use the flat side of your needle.
Pusher and pull out 40 needles.
Notice that the number strip is
marked from the center of the bed.
To put 40 needles into work.
We'll pull out 20 needles on each
side of the imaginary zero.
It's common practice to knit in the middle
of the needle bed, but it's not required.
Most patterns are written
with the assumption that you've positioned
the knitting in the middle of the bed.
For my Caston.
I'm going to put every other
needle into out of work position.
Out of work position is the A
position or all the way back.
The remaining needles can be in B or
D position somewhere in the middle.
Remove the yarn from the yarn clip
and thread it in the yarn feeder.
Wiggle it back and forth to make
sure that it flows evenly.
Keep hold of the tail of yarn with your
left hand and move
the carriage to the left.
You will have loops on every other needle.
I like to use a chip clip or a spring
type clothes pin to secure the yarn tail.
This ensures that the end
stitches knit correctly.
Next, you need to hang your cast on comb
in the loops that you just formed.
If you don't use a cast on comb and you
try to knit back,
you're going to get a mess.
Trust me.
Make sure the Caston comb is in each
one of the loops between the needles.
You can hang a claw weight
in the cast on comb.
This is especially helpful
when Casting on larger pieces.
Pull the out of work needles
into working position.
Having a total of 40 needles in work.
Knit to the right.
You've completed your cast on row.
Now let's stop here for a minute.
The manual tells you to work
the Cast on over 40 needles.
I find that the Cast on comb teeth can be
bent really easy and they're really
wobbly, and I find it easier
to start with every other needle.
Either way, you work it
this is a fast Cast on and it has its uses.
But it is sloppy and it really wouldn't
be appropriate for most knitting.
There are many more Caston
methods you can use.
Knit it Now now has an entire classroom,
course, and five day challenge
covering Caston and find off methods.
You will discover and practice
your own preferred Cast  on method.
For now, we want to just get some stitches
on the machine and explore
the working of the machine.
Now we can start knitting.
The key to success is rhythm.
It's tempting to pass that carriage back
and forth really fast,
especially with small pieces like this.
But consider what's happening
under the carriage.
As you knit,
each needle is being pulled out
in turn.
The working yarn is placed in the hook
of the needle,
and as the needle is pulled back,
the latch of the needle closes and it
pulls that working yarn through the
previous stitch, forming a new stitch.
And at the same time, the next needle is
being positioned to do the same thing.
Knitting quickly can cause
an interruption to this process.
You don't have to go slow,
but an even speed is best give
the carriage time to work its magic.
Another thing to consider.
Do not take the carriage too far
past the end of the knitting.
If you're getting loops on the edges as
you knit, watch that the carriage passes
the edge of the knitting,
but it doesn't pull too much yarn,
forming big old loops on the edges.
You will develop your own rhythm and you
will develop a feel for the edges.
Another thing to consider. As you knit,
there's a lot going on. The yarn is
passing up through that tension mast.
You're watching the carriage
pass back and forth.
The row counter is clicking away.
You're following a pattern.
The knitting is growing before your eyes.
By slowing down, you can easily
keep track of what's happening.
You can look out for knots
in the working yarn.
You can keep track of the number
of rows you're knitting.
You can follow your pattern.
I can't emphasize it enough. For success
with your knitting (large piece or
small piece) knit with an even speed.
Let's knit a few rows
to get a feel for things.
As the knitting grows, you'll want
to hang claw weights along the edge.
Don't worry, they won't
damage your knitting.
They will just help the machine
form the edge stitches correctly
and you can move the claw weights
up as the knitting grows.
For larger pieces,
you'll want to hang claw weights
in the middle of the knitting. Again,
think about how those
stitches are being formed.
If the stitches are loose and sloppy.
As the needle pulls back to form a stitch,
the hook and or the latch can catch
strands, misform stitches and even
jam the carriage. So use weights.
Let's look at the row counter.
If you're a hand knitter,
counting rows may seam foreign to you.
Hand knitters can just simply
measure the length of their knitting
machine.
Knitting add weights and we have the
knitting stretched across the needle bed.
We can't just accurately measure length.
We must count rows and knit the length
according to our row gauge.
As we pass the carriage back and forth,
the row counter Tripper
increments the row counter.
How do we get the knitting
off the machine?
Well, while you're practicing,
the best way is to just break that working
yarn, pass the carriage across and let
the work drop from the machine.
We'll cover binding off in another video
before moving on.
I suggest you cast on knit.
Drop the work a few times.
The more you practice,
the more you'll build your knitting
confidence and make the next steps easier.